samedi soir tf1 lançait en grande pompe
et à grand renfort de promotion la
neuvième saison de l'émission musicale
the voice bonsoir à toutes et à tous un
retour très attendu par les
téléspectateurs qui s'est rapidement
retrouvé en tête des sujets les plus
commentés sur les réseaux faut dire que
la chaîne avait mis les petits plats
dans les grands et avait passé un coup
de balai sur le programme en perte de
vitesse pour enrayer cette chute des
audiences la production a fait le plein
de nouveautés d'abord du côté des
coaches qui ont tous les quatre été
remplacé mika jennifer soprano et julien
clerc ont cédé leur fauteuil à amel bent
marc lavoine pascal obispo et lara
fabian on a assisté à quelque chose de
fabuleux
une mise à jour inédite pour le
programme qui jamais n'avait osé changer
les quatre coachs seule traite
hallucinant mais ce n'est pas tout car
de nombreuses critiques ciblées
également les régles du jeu parfois
difficile à comprendre sans que cela
n'apporte grand chose aux anges ne
s'étaient pas très très très très bien
du coup les producteurs ont souhaité
revenir aux fondamentaux en allant
chercher plus de candidats amateurs et
moins de voix semi professionnel dans le
format les choses ont également été
changés fini la saison à rallonge cette
année des épisodes seront plus resserré
et moins nombreux merci côté règle c'est
le public qui choisira les quatre
finalistes fini aussi les vols de talent
et bienvenue au retour de la règle qui
permet au couple de se retourner et de
parler avec le talent même s'il n'a pas
été sélectionné bref le moins que l'on
puisse dire c'est que tf1 aura tout fait
pour protéger l'une de ses marques les
plus importantes alors le retour de the
voice
j'aime ou j'aime pas
je ne vous aime pas c'est vrai que sur
les réseaux sociaux ils sont fait
défoncer au vote j'ai pas compris un
déferlement comme ça alors attend
d'avoir votre avis on va voir
l'ouverture des quatre côtes puisqu'ils
sont arrivés sur the show must go de
queen regardez
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
j'aime ils viennent pas on va démarrer
pas à kelly vous aimez moi j'aime parce
que justement je trouve qu'ils ont fait
l'effort de changer ce que le public ne
met pas dans le passé et je trouve que
justement on voit les modifications et
moi ça me plaît de plus en plus et le
jury m'a je le trouvais au top mais
alors alors et et le jury les gens n'ont
pas du tout accroché cassation j'ai
adoré
oui bien aux gens tout voiture que
l'émission allait beaucoup trop axée sur
les coaches d ouverture de l'émission où
nous vend pascal obispo lara fabian marc
lavoine etc ils essaient de créer une
fausse rumeur entre les coaches dès le
début ou saas vannes ça se fait des
blagues je trouve ça sonne très faux et
c'est plus centré sur les talents et moi
j'ai un autre problème avec the voice et
que ça fait deux trois saisons qu'on n'a
aucun talent qui a été révélée par the
voice comme c'était il ya quelques
années avec angie lou anne walryck qu'on
a fait la saison il a gagné à saison
thierry henry non non explosées il ya
celui ci le petit belge on le verra je
me suis après merci la transversale et
c'est vrai c'est vrai que ça fait deux
trois ans qui a plus de talent qui se
répète moi j'ai trouvé le jury
exceptionnel auriez eu un premier clash
entre pascal obispo amel ben ils sont
pas du tout d'accord sur un talon et
j'ai trouvé que c'était la première fois
qu'on avait comme ça des joutes verbales
comme ça dans the voice
voilà alors qu'avant c'était plutôt un
moment donné je me dis mais comment elle
va faire quand il va falloir qu'elles
sont par exemple une chanson de léo
ferré
mais mes pascal excuse moi je te connais
tu n'as pas laisser non mais pardon dire
ça mais géra une chanteuse excuse-moi
lui demander de ses passes à ses réseaux
mais l'appel commun qui peut le plus
peut le moins je suis pas d'accord avec
toi qui peut le plus peut le moins ce
que je peux finir ce cas peut très bien
déchirer allait resserrer mais justement
là mais elle aime laisser finir oui les
flux on est tous dans tes doigts oui
c'est à dire vous me laissez pas finir
ça y est tu as tout dit je sais pas
s'ils étaient bilingues mais lors hynix
et des mots et c'est des grands mots
j'aimerais moi aussi je suis bien
l'auteur de sa génération alors il ya
des gens qui ont vraiment très déçu cela
commence très mal on regarde pas ce vote
pour voir des gens s'engueuler seul
marqué et timide mais correct et c'est
vrai quoi là et je vous dis oui je sais
gérer le match bonsoir
non moi sont justement c'est ce que j'ai
aimé
on n'a pas arrêté de dire que c'était un
jury de bisounours qu'ils étaient
contraints suez étant d'accord pour une
fois ils n'étaient pas d'accord y en a
qui disait arrête de chanter et des
chanteurs qui disaient non je veux tu
chantes tu pousses la voie pour une fois
on avait décidé des conversations un
petit peu technique on comprenait
pourquoi il se retourner ou pas alors
que nous néophyte
on peut parfois on n'était pas d'accord
avec eux mais au moins il ya des
explications et on avait quatre vraies
personnalités
on peut aimer de façon individuelle et
les quatre ans semble fonctionner aussi
bravo et ils sont revenus en plus aux
fondamentaux en enlevant tous les
scories qu'ils avaient rajouté au fil
des saisons
donc peut-être qu'on va à nouveau
retrouvée du 2-2 alors à me remettre
elle a fait le choix fou voilà est pour
beaucoup de gens c'est vrai car là qui
ont dit qu'elle en faisait trop moi je
les trouvais éclipse vraiment pour moi
si je pense la meilleure juré on est une
danseuse russe a prévu voilà c'est passé
mon avis mais c'est vrai que les gens
n'ont pas accroché comme moi enfin l'a
pas fait l'unanimité mais c'est pour ça
aussi parce que si c'est une grosse
personnalité ont regardé elle était
formidable
bonsoir bonsoir je vais commencer par un
compliment ça va paraître bizarre parce
qu'on s'est pas retourné c'était bien tu
aimes tu peux être fier de toi c'était
bien parce que moi j'ai trouvé que tu
avais une voix mais arrête jamais tu
sais tu sais que j'ai des cheveux quand
même maghrébins
t'es juste belle mais comme jamais on
liner a coulé mais c'est pas grave ça y
est on a fini maintenant tu as fais ce
que tu devais faire tu peux pleurer tu
peut relâcher la pression tout ça finit
là je peux parler de toi jusqu'à demain
en tout cas pas celle à celle avancée
qui était servi
c'est toi tu va bloquer ou débloquer
pascal
[Applaudissements]
moi c'est très mal à moi même si pagny
moment que j'aime bien le jury s'il s'en
sort quand il se laisse pas parler mais
avant j'étais sidéré du nombre de fois
où ils n'arrêtent pas de dire oh mais
qu'est ce que c'était bien mais qu'est
ce que c'est humain causé par tourner on
sait bien que l'avoine a présenté ses
lexus il est des fois c'était assez bien
parce qu'en matière première énorme
c'était aveugle et peaufiné ensuite
alors faire quelque chose alors baisse
de m'embêter
amel zen bien il y en a plein qui ont
critiqué sa robe en velours aussi je
vous lis amel bent a sorti sa robe du
plat de la rom du placard de sa grand
mère trop peu plus de la robe et qui
s'en serait de amel bent on dirait
presque qu'elle un troisième sens à
cause de son dessous de bras
voilà donc les gens étaient un peu la
nation je vous dis même là le prix de sa
robe a été révélé oui 1560 ils ont fait
ça toute la saison dernière avec mélanie
faire ils vont le faire avec amel bent
et avec le même design vient d'ailleurs
quoi vous n'avez pas aimé les jambes et
six champions puisqu'elle a même tenu à
les voir contre au moins habillée comme
ça exactement ça entrecoupé soit en tout
cas moi j'ai détesté sur la comme chaque
année voilà il n'y a pas de chaufferie
c'est un défi pour cette année cette
année on a des gens qui sont bien en
france ou même à quelle surprise
évidemment le jury encore qui se
retourne pas mais une fois guy samson le
pas une fois qu'ils sont ils sortent ou
l'eau avec la production
les havrais serait fantastique croit tes
rêves accroche toi et cetera non tu te
retourne pas qu'il a vraiment eu une
question bien sûr j'ai regardé j'ai
besoin de ce tri j'apprécie c'est les
frères orthodoxes
j'ai trouvé super bien mais évidemment
personne s'est retourné voilà et le jury
qu'un supporter alba lieu de l'améliorer
se prendra jamais lara fabian est
insupportable donner des leçons à tout
le monde a eu marre et les techniques et
de suicide avant la télé vous jeter par
la fenêtre et dépressif
[Musique]
franchement il est très drôle très drôle
on appliquait la bonne celle là je suis
pas d'accord les deux sont très classe
elle a alors l'eau douce que l'alors
yannick au ceci qui a fait john baird &
co ce qu'il a fait il a fait deux hommes
1 samedi soir
nico si l'animateur et community manager
il est tout le temps sur ce résultat va
pousser plus du tout dans l'émission
bonjour comment ça va vous êtes qui dans
la salle
la maman inquiète pas amis histoire
donc là que ce soit
temps des boys ou cesser pour elle en
fait c'est ça ouais mais toutes les
mamans ça si on est bien après une
émission c'est déjà un naufrage une
belle bête la pauvre un belle bête
intelligente qui sent que ça ne marche
pas qu'ils se démet communes yonne ont
la critique parce qu'elle en fait trop
mais elle voit qu'il ya le désert à côté
d'elle énarque la royne obispo
totalement absent non à fabian mais à la
fois un comment peut-on être à la fois
insupportable et absorber les chocs
émotionnels
elle est lancée nul je suis foulé nikos
c'est vous crée bien nick nikos
transparent totalement absent du
communiqué ce qui fait il n'a pas dit un
mot
quant au talent et anvers à nikos il est
jamais il a lâché la rampe donc très
franchement vous êtes dur je crois que
je suis là où je vous rejoins c'est amel
bent tout le reste est une tragédie t on
n'aura pas la prestation à vous donner
votre avis l'une des prestations qui a
plus ému les téléspectateurs c'est celle
de maria une chanteuse irlandaise non
voyantes regarde moi c'est maria et je
suis irlandaise j'habite en lorraine
avec un homme marié mais cet enfant me
sens j'ai c'est que ça se voit pas mais
je suis aussi aveugle
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
merci
du lara fabian voilà comme coach à l'âme
aussi fait l'eurovision 1988 pour la
belgique
on n'aimait pas pourquoi on va déjà
justement par rapport à cette pauvre
nation on donne le portrait avant qui
chante on vous explique la vie avant qui
chante comme le principe c'est de se
retourner sur simplement une voix de
nous polluer pas avec leur vie lors
leurs malheurs qui doit arriver les cds
chanter et à prométhée le portrait et
c'est vrai que pour le jury j'ai adoré
marc lavoine j'ai adoré pascal et c'est
vrai que j'ai eue de le dire alors que
ses deux copines et j'ai eu du mal avec
les filles parce qu'effectivement
c'était de la surenchère et moi ça va
déranger
voilà dans la façon de bala après ça peu
après vous dites et après vous dites
linverse aux dépens du jury interne ont
reproché au jury ne pas être incident
avec des candidats ils ont pas ils sont
pas pour ce fight et sont là pour donner
des conseils et des candidats et
effectivement ils peuvent ne pas être
d'accord sur le candidat mais pas ce
singe activée moi ça m'a dérangé alors
qu'il ya aussi une autre prestation qui
a été très commenté sur twitter c'est
celle d'antoine il fait déjà fait déjà
lancé déjà figure de grand favori de la
compet de la compet
[Musique]
il fait beau
mais quand même pas
et c'est bon
[Musique]
ap
le
j'adore cette émission mais c'est vrai
qu'elle était un petit peu en perte de
vitesse
et là j'ai trouvé qu'il t'avait
régénérer rebooster
moi j'ai trouvé ça exceptionnel et
surtout je suis en adoration total pour
ce jury alors un modèle
franchement je trouve que c'est une
rolls on est rarement vu quelqu'un
d'aussi bons comme gérer dans une
émission et on a toujours un petit
complexe en france d'infériorité par
rapport aux émissions américaines où on
dit toujours qu'on a des jurys un peu en
dessous et là vraiment ils sont tous les
quatre
incroyable et oui cabotine mais c'est ça
aussi ça fait partie du show certainment
et j'ai trouvé lara fabian très
technique très précise mireille
compétents rôle r je les ai trouvés tout
incroyable charismatique pour l'un très
4 sincère pour courbis peau et voilà et
moi je trouve que le cabotinage fait
partie aussi de ce show et toi aussi tu
sur you with you dude il est comme ça
cette soirée sera vengé ce l'émotion
c'est ce que ça c'est pas mal alors
certains internautes se sont étonnés de
voir des prêtres passer les auditions à
la boc deux aux russes
alors on va en voir leur prestation à 0
qu'ils apprennent sur twitter qui se
sont étonnés regarder
[Musique]
et
[Applaudissements]
oh
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
non
mon chat à mon coach écosse
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
une petite polémique là-dessus sur les
pattes dans ce vol il ya littéralement
des prêtres en tenue qui viennent faire
des chants religieux mais mesnel rap et
de medel a été tel à cause d'un turban
non j'aime la viande ce alors benjamin
est d'accord à monaco bien sûr
évidemment je dois tout sera tourné il
ya eu bel et bien une polaire l'arbre on
est dans une équipe étaient dus y
compris j'ai reprocher l'épaule j'ai
effectivement ça pouvait déranger
pourquoi on va reprocher crée d'abord à
d'abord un voile ou un turban sur la
tête
ah non mais moi alors ben alors écoutez
là on va pas faire de à un blanc ou noir
glossy d'accord moi je suis d'accord
alors on avait reposé ses tweets année
après année je vais payer unis si ça
dérange vous adonner à des gens sur
twitter que sa cheville et tu supportes
pas dire quoi que non mais après dans la
polémique tout tout tout s'est enchaîné
on lui a reproché son bose qu'on fait
des tweets
je suis assez bon pour moi je comprends
très bien qu'on ait leçon puisque vous
trouvé ça curieux qu'on on accepte pour
des prêtres il a déconné c'est à dire
par là il ya un problème
gisèle sa pensée par jean effectivement
il ya eu plusieurs temps si vous m'avez
il est bien il ya une apparence ou des
gens bien sûr et c'est pas la seule qui
pour une apparence a été jugé en france
ça va le faire
sauf que change sommet n'ait lieu le
jury s'était retourné hélas pour eux le
jury ne s'est pas retourné mes 15 ans
alors mais c'est après coup mais ça n'a
rien à reprocher à mes mails des tweeds
nous n'avons jamais n'avoir voile
nous nous verrons mais comme ça on va
s'éclater c'était des gens sont déjà sur
les réseaux sociaux et qui se plaignait
du doigt le raymond moi j'aime bien
qu'ils ont ils ont refait le jury quand
vous dites que le jury ait pas valable
et où c'est des gens qui remplissent des
salles cgnews des cdc et vendent encore
détruit moi j'adore marquer je vais vous
dire je regardais pas moi the voice cd34
annexant passé et j'ai été juste pour
marc lavoine parce que j'adore ce mec et
il m'emmenait sur the voice j'ai trouvé
bien je peux être florent pagny me
manque aussi un peu parce que j'adore
florent pagny j'ai trouvé maria qui a
chanté
j'aimerais bien avoir chanté don't cry
for me argentine puisque je pense
qu'elle a une pure voix au lieu de 80
ans
l'occasion vous dire antoine de chanter
du balavoine
mais moi je trouve qu'ils ont fait un
bon choix obispo et amel il faut pas
trop qui il faut pas trop qui s'énerve
parce que on est bien placé et 50 quand
ça s'énerve les gens les aiment pas mal
que moi j'adore j'aime bien ça va vous
sinon le moral pour le jury déjà que le
jury 54% des gens qui aiment pas et sur
les missions les chéris leur tour de
rôle et je vous le dis moi j'ai bien
aimé e adhérents mais de ce que j'ai vu
sur les réseaux sociaux
je pense que ça va être une catastrophe
d'audience the voice est animé millions
ça fait de la peine de dire ça mais je
vous dis ça va être un drame parce qu'il
n'y avait rien en face la semaine
dernière et cette nation à brochets des
guérillas les grosses têtes déjà ça va
mieux marché nommé julie ça ne marche et
que ce qu'ils avaient cette semaine sur
france 2 il y avait et c'était pas un
inédit soit en trois mois ce qui n'était
pas née donc je peux vous dire ça va
être un drame et j'ai vu de ce que j'ai
lu sur les réseaux sociaux
ça va être très très très très dur et je
devrais je pense avec une saison
cauchemar